our single best chart looks at the
triggers of bear markets in equity
oh I'm shocked speaking of I'm
absolutely shy there you go okay I'm
ready it shows how bear markets don't
just pop out of the air they're caused
by Tight money recessions by Tight money
or processions or in some cases both so
what you have here is a year-over-year
uh percent change in the S P 500 the big
plunges come during either a Fed
tightening circles which are the yellow
circles or recessions which are the red
circles according to David Rosenberg uh
based on the trends in the conference
boards leading economic index of
recession is at least two years away and
any rate increase is not likely to
happen until mid 2015 at the earliest if
not 2016 if you look at some of the
market expectations so we're a long way
away from any kind of bear Market